en direct dans ce gîte et guy mettan
député au grand conseil du canton de
genève et ex directeur du critique du
club de la presse club suisse de la
presse bonjour guy mettan merci de
répondre à nos questions question
comment il faut interpréter cette
décision des partis conservateurs suisse
de s'opposer à la création d'une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire
écoutez ça n'est pas surprise dans la
mesure où on sait que les partis
majoritaires dans ce pays le parti
démocrate-chrétien parti libéral radical
et est opposé à l'application d'une
commission d'enquêté que leur décision
n'est pas une surprise elle se comprend
pour la bonne raison que beaucoup de
personnalités ces divers partis sont
impliqués dans la vie un crypto parce
qu'elle siégeait au conseil
d'administration
ils ont d'autre part et il était une
connaissaient l'implication des services
secrets américains et allemands dont
crypto donc à partir de ce moment là ils
ne sont pas présentes ou dias tu
pourrais un commission donc cela dit le
parlement accord décidé de mener une
investigation avec un juge qui a été
nommé à cette fonction d'ailleurs
pendant que ses pédales donc il y aura
une enquête mais ça n'est pas au niveau
de leurs la commission d' enquête
parlementaire d'un niveau à un tout
petit peu inférieur attendant le pays du
secret bancaire pourquoi cette affaire
la sphère crypto divise autant la
neutralité suisse et un trail par la
sphère crypto bah oui évidemment parce
que normalement un pays neutre se doit
d'observer de rester disons un pas
impartial en tout cas équilibrée entre
les diverses nations doit éviter disons
de prendre parti en tout cas trop
ostensiblement et là dans le cas présent
ça n'a pas du tout été le cas puisque je
sois très clair a été faire aux faveurs
de la cia et du bnd l'immédiat mais en
plus il ya eu un sentiment présent
puisque 120 pays ont été trompés sur la
marchandise et cela délibérément donc
c'est une affaire
gravité extrême à la fois pour la
réputation de la suisse à l'étranger
vis-à-vis des pays qui ont été trompés
et puis évidemment un sujet de la
neutralité la neutralité figure dans la
constitution fédérale suisse
deux articles ils sont consacrés et donc
à présent elle a naturellement été
bafoués
donc c'est un scandale de première
ampleur et j'espère effectivement qu'une
enquête qui sera menée aboutir à des
résultats et permettra à l'avenir
d'éviter ce type de compromission dit
mettant dernière question rapidement n'a
plus beaucoup de temps les médias
français par le peu de cette affaire
comment est ce que vous expliquez que ce
dossier crucial du renseignement passe
sous les radars ailleurs qu'en suisse
ben la france par chance n'a pas acheté
le matériel clip tôle de la société
crypte où elle disposait de ses propres
de ses propres instruments de ses
propres machines de cryptage donc dans
ce cas dans le cas présent il n'a pas
été touché
d'autre part on peut comprendre ses
réactions parce que les pays qui ont été
trompés n'ont pas non plus un intérêt à
dire et ont proclamé sur la place
publique des choses qui vont se régler
dix ans de silence ou la confidentialité
de diplomatie mais évident que déjà
c'est un certain nombre de pays de ces
pays auraient agi auprès de la
diplomatie suisse
merci à guy mettan d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
député au grand conseil du canton de
genève et ex directeur du club suisse de
la presse